my name is Shakir and I'm a mechanical
engineer student I would like to ask you
a question that uh how can you prove to
an ethe
scientifically the existence of
God the brother POS the question how can
you scientifically prove the existence
of God Almighty the existence of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
to especially to an
atheist who does not believe in
God the first thing I will do is that I
will congratulate that atheist I
congratulate him you know why if you
look around us he's a Hindu because
father is a Hindu he's a Christian
because father is a Christian some
Muslims are Muslims because their
fathers are Muslim this person though he
may be coming from a religious
background he does not believe in the
false god which is parents attribute to
so he does not believe in God I'm
congratulating him because he's accepted
the first part of the shahada the first
part of the Islamic
Creed there is no God now my job is to
prove ill but Allah which I shall do
inshallah to the other people I have to
first remove the wrong concept of God
and then prove the right concept of
Allah subhana wa tala here half my job
is done he has already
said there's no God now I have to prove
illah but Allah la which I shall do
inshallah you ask this atheist that
Suppose there is an object an
unidentified maybe a flying object which
no one in the world has seen no human
being in the world knows about his
object if it's brought in front of you
and if you asked that who will be the
first person who will be able to tell
you the mechanism of this unidentified
object question who is the first person
who will be able to tell you the
mechanism of this new object which no
one in the world has
seen after thinking for a while he'll
give the answer the person who will be
able to tell you the mechanism the first
person is the creator of that
object some may say manufacturer some
may say producer whatever they say don't
grapple with the word accept it it will
be somewhat similar either Creator or
producer
or manufacturer but remember what he has
told you keep it in your mind then ask
him the next question how did the
universe come into existence how was it
form he will tell you by The Big Bang
Theory tell him the Quran mentions in
Surah Amia CH 21 verse number 30 about
the Big Bang Theory who could have
mentioned this in the Quran 1400 years
ago so he will tell you maybe it's a Flo
don't argue with him next part of the
question we did not know
the light of the moon is reflected light
we came to know
recently you ask him you told yes yes
the light of the moon is reflected light
it's not its own light when we
discovered he will tell you recently
yesterday 50 years back 100 years back
yesterday in fans you tell him the Quran
mentions that the light of the moon is
reflected light 1,400 years ago who
could have mentioned that maybe somebody
had a wild guess don't argue with them
continue we thought the sun was
stationary you ask him is it stationary
you say no it's rotating and
revolving when you learn this he will
tell you yesterday 50 years back 100
years back Quran mentions this 1400
years ago he will hesitate but may say
maybe some intelligent person roted
don't argue with him
continue how was the universe initially
what a cal matter he will tell you it
was Smoke how did you come to know we
have got proof we have got evidence you
tell him Quran mentioned this 14 years
ago who could have mentioned that he
will
hesitate don't wait for response
continue keep on posing question after
question all that I give the lecture
keep on posing one question after the
other that water cycle how do we come to
know about it Quran mentioned 400 years
ago about every living thing made from
water who could I mention that Quran
speaks about botany the male and female
who could have mention that pause one
after the other and ask the question who
could have written
that then you tell him that there's a
theory known as theory of
probability that if you have two Choice
out of which one is right the chances
that you will make the correct
choice just at random is one and two for
example if I toss a coin it can either
be heads or tails
the chances that I'll be right will be
one and two if I toss it twice the
chances that I'll be right both the
times will be 1 upon 2 multip 1 upon 2
that is 1 upon 4 25%
chance if I toss it thce chances I'll be
right all three times 1 upon 2 multi 1
upon 2 multi 1 upon 2 it's 1 upon 8 12
half% a dice has got six sides if I
throw a dice the chances that at random
I'll be correct is 1 upon six if I throw
it Twi ice the chances that both the
time I'll be right will be 1 upon 6 by 1
upon 6 1 upon
36 this is called as theory of
probability if I throw the dice twice
and then toss a coin all three being
right will be 1 upon 6 by 1 upon 6 by 1
upon 2 is 1 upon
72 so you ask him the chances maybe if
you ask
what is the shape of the
earth there are various shapes some may
say it is flat some may say it's
triangular some may say it is hexagonal
some may say pentagonal some may say
heptagonal some may say Square say they
can be 10
shapes some may say it is round it is
sperical the chances that if anyone
makes a wild guess it being correct is 1
upon
10 the light of the Moon it can e be its
own light or it can be reflected light
the chances that you make a wild guess
and it being correct will be one upon
two the chances that both shape of the
earth and light of the Moon being
reflected light both being correct if
you make a wild guess it will be 1 upon
10 multip 1 upon 2 it is 1 upon
20 what can the living creatures be made
of some may say sand some may say Stone
some may say aluminium some may say gold
say a thousand materials you can name
some may say water some may say silver a
thousand material the chances that you
make a wild guess and one of them being
right according to mathematics is one
upon a thousand the chances that all
three being correct the Earth is
spherical light of the moon is reflected
light and every living creature created
from water is correct will be one upon
10 multip 1 upon 2 multip 1 upon th000
answer comes to 1 upon 20,000 or
05% Quran speaks about scientific signs
more than a thousand verses in three
versus the chance comes to
05% if you apply probability Theory to
all this being at random chance it will
come to zero negligible and in math
anything one in 10 raed to 50 it's equal
to
zero so you ask your atheist friend who
could have written this the only answer
I can give you is his first answer the
Creator the
manufacturer the person who has produced
it that's the only answer there's no
other answer what science is saying
today is they are not eliminating God
they are eliminating models of
God ill they are not eliminating God but
models of God I hope to answer the
question